what's going on guys in this review i'm
going to be breaking down episode 16 of
attack on titan season 4
which is the last episode for this half
of the season today i'll be talking
about everything that i felt needed
explaining
such as why this titan shoved zeke into
his stomach and how aaron already knew
that marley had infiltrated the island
before we begin i really want to thank
you guys for watching my episode
breakdowns for this season so far
i mean prior to the season i didn't
really do much attack on titan content
on youtube at least
um so it really has blown me away your
support we even managed to get trending
on youtube a couple of times which was
insane
so i just want to say i really do
appreciate it when the second half of
the season starts again i will of course
be doing more breakdown videos
so hit that sub button to make sure you
don't miss those and drop a like as it
does help out the channel
okay so episode 16 was called above and
below and it starts off immediately
after zeke's suicidal explosion
the sound of the detonation was enough
to get the attention of hanji and the
yagaris who were already on their way to
his location
as we know hanji is one of the handful
of people that knew where zeke was being
held hostage
hence why they've been forced at
gunpoint to bring flock to those
coordinates
i gotta say it would have been
interesting to see what the yagrits
would have done if they arrived and had
to face off against levi
but luckily for them he was out of
commission in this scene we see that
zeke has literally been ripped in half
and i probably don't need to tell you
that regular titan shifter healing
cannot fix this
the anime does a good job of conveying
his gradual death as the sound of the
rain stops while zeke begins to lose his
senses
in normal circumstances this would have
been the end for the beast titan but a
few interesting things happened from
this point onwards
firstly he briefly sees a vision of a
random girl holding a bucket
and she seems to have a similar
hairstyle to this mural of the original
founding titan
this original titan was of course called
ymir and she was known to have made a
deal with the devil to gain her titan
powers
although as tom salva alluded to maybe
she got those powers by touching
something else instead
the girl's eyes have a hollow look to
them similar to how we've seen
other characters when they've
experienced immense pain or when they're
being forced to do something they don't
want to do
so this kind of indicates to us that
there's something she's not happy about
this vision is then followed by one of
the pure titans he created coming back
from the dead
but i need to remind you guys that this
is the same titan that had his head
crushed and his body ripped apart not
that long ago
it grabs what's left of zeke's dying
body before shoving it inside his guts
and out of context this is one of the
most bizarre moments in the history of
the series
from the smoke we can tell that the pure
titan is still regenerating
so by putting zeke inside it the
intention is that he will also be able
to regenerate as well
that being said this scene was the last
moment we got to see of him in this
episode
meaning that his fate and levi's fate
won't be revealed until the second half
of the season
the animation switches over to elena
having lunch with commander pixis
as the aegis now have full control of
parody silence until recently
the military on parodies was trying to
resist the takeover with pixes plotting
different ways to steal the fighting
titan from eren
however they had no choice but to
surrender after this moment
since zeke's scream made them realize
they could be turned into titans at any
time
the commander knew it would be pointless
to put up a fight because when your
enemy can turn you into a mindless
monster
it's just not worth taking the risk many
episodes ago when zeke first arrived on
the island
elena and the volunteers were all held
at gunpoint but even then she remained
calm
and said one day they would eat at the
same table again at the time we didn't
know why she was so relaxed but it's
because she knew that pixis and the
other military officials
had been contaminated with the wine and
that they'd soon be forced into this
position
here she makes good on that promise that
they'd all be dying at the same table
although pixis himself was refusing to
eat
we get a few relevant bits of info out
of their conversation with the first
being that all military soldiers have
been gathered in shiganjana
before the jaeger's takeover occurred
shiganchena was already set to be
evacuated since zachary wanted to use it
as a testing ground for the rumbling
as a result it meant that no civilians
were in the district which is why it's
the only safe place for these
contaminated soldiers to go
elena has made the soldiers where
different armbands to indicate their new
status
with the white bands meaning they've
willingly defected to the aegiris and
likely was on their side even before the
truth of the wine was revealed
red armbands indicate they've been
forced to work for the igris after
finding out about the wine
and the black armbands just mean you're
screwed given that aaron zeke and elena
will be in charge of the island for the
foreseeable future
people with the black armbands will have
the lowest social standing in society
which pix's notes is very similar to how
marley does things
in the last episode we discovered that
zeke's true intention is to eliminate
the aldean race
therefore saving the world from the
titans and saving the eldens from their
suffering
the only people who knew about that true
plan were the yeager brothers themselves
and elena because she was the one that
told aaron about it during their secret
meeting
other volunteers like onyankapon had no
idea so when she sort of let it slip
during this conversation
it understandably gets a shocked
reaction from the crowd these guys never
assumed there was another ulterior
motive
as far as they were concerned this
takeover of the island was just a way
for them to live in luxury
you can tell in the following scenes
that onyankapon is somewhat
uncomfortable with the way things are
progressing
but for now at least he has to go along
with it because understandably he does
not want his brains blown out by elena
previously we saw that after aaron was
finished beating up and insulting his
friends
he ordered for them to be sent to
shiganjana which is where they're locked
up in this underground prison
i explained in my review of episode 14
why shiganchina is likely the place
where zeke and aaron agreed to meet so
it's interesting that he would demand
that armin mikasa and the rest of the
gang be sent to the same location as
well
he could have had them sent to any
prison but for some reason he chose one
in shiganshina and in the jail cell
jean questions whether eren might have a
hidden motive after
all he's doing a lot of things that are
out of character but for now this
question remains up in the air
when elena arrives she explains the full
details of the true plan
and this scene where she shoots griez is
very interesting as it shows us just how
much he buys into zeke's philosophy
zeke believes his plan will save the
eldian race from suffering so he sees it
as something that will help them rather
than hurt them
and this is exactly what elena thinks as
well that's why when this guy was
disrespecting sasha by calling her a
devil
he was unknowingly showing that he
wasn't on board with zeke's plan clearly
he sees aliens as lesser than himself
and never sought to actually help them
by any definition of the word
so by default that mindset doesn't
really go hand in hand with what elaine
is trying to achieve
onyankapon once mentioned that elena
would kill anyone who doubted her
with this just being another example in
a long list of casualties
as a side note it was cool to find out
that nicola was romantically in love
with sasha
like obviously we suspected it but it
was never 100 confirmed to be romantic
until this moment
moving over to gabby she was locked up
in a different room by herself
and that's because aaron had very
specific plans before we get into that
though
it's important to note that she seems to
be confused here as there's a small
detail that the anime left out
during the equivalent scene in the manga
gabby was explicitly shown to be
thinking about sasha's family crying
and she felt guilty for making them feel
that pain that's why she's questioning
herself
since she can't understand the reason
she feels this way despite them being
island devils
this is one more step in gabby's long
path to de-radicalization
as she is slowly beginning to realize
that they are all the same
anyway aaron shows up and asks gabby to
help him locate the marlin invaders
considering that both peak and porco had
already infiltrated the walls
if you've seen my video about the car
titans then you'll know they have the
best endurance out of any shifter
and as a result pique used it to walk
from the shore of parodies
all the way up until the wars themselves
poco presumably was riding on her back
but one thing they couldn't avoid was
her titan footprints being left in the
grass
one of the agris must have discovered
those massive prince and reported back
to aaron which is why he was certain
that there were spies in the first place
however he didn't even have time for
gabby to help him before pique finally
made her reappearance
and kills the guard immediately despite
two guns being pointed directly at him
aaron seemed pretty certain that he
wouldn't die cause he believed the
warriors didn't have permission to kill
the founding titan
we know this theory is true because
earlier this season mcgas stated that
killing the founder would only postpone
the problem
and that molly needs to gain the founder
for itself therefore both peak and gabby
would be in serious trouble if they
broke the rules
and aaron is correct to say that their
families would likely suffer the
consequences
from the beginning pique's real goal was
to lure eren into a position where poco
could eat him
and she did this in a very clever way by
pretending that she was working against
marley it was enough to gain eren's
curiosity i mean yeah he didn't trust
her but he was still intrigued as to
whether or not she was willing to expose
her comrades
by going to the roof she promised to
expose the location of the spies on
paradise
and on the way she saw poco in the crowd
and signaled to him which you know let
him know where they were going
that's why he knew where to burst in to
eat eren although sadly for them he
literally just missed
when she tried to get parker's attention
a few soldiers were surprised
that this short girl was really amalian
warrior but what surprised me was that
so many of them were simps
by my account that's at least six elden
soldiers who are blushing at the sight
of peak
so i guess it's a good thing that
isayama didn't stick with his original
design
now the reality is that when she was
trying to convince erin she was
betraying marley
most of what pique said was still true
it is the reality that eldins will never
truly be viewed
as anything other than people who can
turn into titans and like grisha said in
the last episode
they are doomed to be trapped unless
someone changes something
being able to acknowledge that shows
that peek is at least aware that the
fate of the eldian race is not looking
so good
and so in this situation that was enough
to get eren's interest
he attached peak to gabby with handcuffs
to ensure that she wouldn't transform
into the card titan
because the explosive transformation
would kill the warrior candidate
immediately
during their walk to the roof it's clear
that neither she nor mali
know exactly why zeke has such special
powers but pique was clever enough to
speculate that he can draw out the power
of the founding titan
time and time again she has proven
herself to be the most observant of the
current warriors
and on this occasion it was zeke's words
back in season 3 that made her come to
this realization
until then she always felt like zeke was
lying but in this moment when zeke met
his younger brother
she could tell that he was telling the
truth so when you look at the full
context of the situation now
that's why she assumed that maybe he
could help aaron use the founding titan
she later questions why erin isn't using
the founder which is yet another way of
her assessing just how much of the power
he can use
as they reach the roof yelena has a
firing squad ready to go in case pique
tricks them
and of course aaron had already cut his
finger in case he needed to transform
this was really a life or death
situation for the warriors gabby in
particular
but at this moment poco bursts through
the roof and eats aaron's legs
this prompted aaron to transform as well
and i'm pretty sure it's the first time
we've seen mapper animate
either of these titans in 2d with the
attack titan looking especially good
in the ideal scenario galliard would
have eaten the spine and would have
inherited the founding titan
attack titan and warhammer titan in this
one bite
so it is unlucky that he literally
missed by inches regardless
the smoke from this transformation was
enough for incoming malian forces to
pinpoint the founder's location
aboard the airship his cult whose main
priority is to save falco
and obviously reiner is there as well
who has come to get revenge for liberio
without reiner's interference
marley was going to wait six months to
launch an attack with the rest of the
world
so this upcoming battle right now is
really all down to him
the episode ends with aaron staring down
the enemy ships and of course this
battle will be continued in the second
half of the season
if you're an anime only then do let me
know in the comments are you going to
wait for the next episode in like maybe
10 months time or do you think you're
gonna read the manga in the meantime
like i said thank you guys for watching
my episode breakdown so far and despite
the season being on break there are
still many more videos to come so hit
that sub button if you haven't already
until the next one peace out